lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
comparar inversión y consumo y lo
pensaremos en dos contextos uno al que
yo llamaré el contexto cotidiano el de
día a día y el otro sería pensarlo en el
contexto de economía pongo aquí consumo
y bueno porque bueno estas dos palabras
tienen significados muy particulares
especialmente para un economista y lo
que haremos es usar estas dos palabras
estas terminologías clasificaciones como
lo quieras llamar para entender de dónde
viene el pib dibujo aquí una línea una
línea para separar ambos contextos y
aquí tengo yo el cotidiano nuestras
conversaciones diarias de estos dos
términos y acá abajo tengo economía el
término bueno el punto de vista desde
economía el contexto que usan los
economistas especialmente visto en
términos para cuando se contabiliza para
el pib
no son necesariamente tan diferentes
pero sí lo son en importantes maneras
ahora inversión en ambos casos puede ser
visto generalmente como algo que tú
haces para en el futuro obtener alguna
ganancia como por ejemplo si yo hoy
construyó una casa este este punto
representa mi casa y yo construye una
una línea del tiempo verdad entonces
bueno es una inversión porque me da la
ganancia futura de aquí a un año yo
podré seguir viviendo en esa casa
entonces un pro es que yo no pagaré
renta y así año tras año yo sigo sin
pagar renta entonces me me seguirá dando
algún tipo de ganancia o algún tipo de
ahorro una fianza es un instrumento
financiero quizás tú compras una fianza
que es esencialmente tu prestando dinero
a alguien más
eso es una inversión porque en el
sentido cotidiano cuando tú compraste
ese activo te dará ganancias futuras en
el sentido de bueno los pagos de interés
ahora otro ejemplo que yo considero como
inversión es ir a la universidad ir a la
universidad lo considero como una
inversión lo pongo aquí como educación
la educación porque bueno
es tiempo y energía en la educación y
eso te dará frutos en el transcurso del
tiempo ojalá que estudiando sea el caso
que qué bueno recibas un mejor empleo
mejor salario mejores oportunidades por
el resto de tu vida y por eso lo
considero como una inversión
ahora la noción día a día de consumo tú
estás usando algo tú estás comprando
algo que usarás en un corto plazo sea
cual sea este objeto tú bueno lo gastas
lo usas al máximo y en alguna manera te
beneficia pero estamos hablando algo más
a corto plazo y a eso yo lo considero
consumo en términos cotidianos
entonces si tú vas y compras por ejemplo
a la tienda un dulce y te lo comes tú
has consumido algo consumista el dulce y
bueno no existe un no es no existe una
inversión vaya ahora si tú vas al cine
eso es consumo y no estoy diciendo que
algo sea mejor que lo otro pero bueno en
la inversión lo que haces es invertir
para obtener un beneficio futuro que te
podría llevar al consumo y al fin de
cuentas el consumo será algo que hará tu
vida mejor en ciertas maneras
sumo sería por ejemplo también comprar
un cd una película ver una película es
consumo y también por ejemplo comprar un
libro es bueno podemos debatir en si es
educativo o no pero asumimos que
compraste un libro que no es educativo
entonces también eso es consumo el
consumo hace que tu vida sea más feliz
sea mejor en algunas maneras las
definiciones manejadas en economía están
relacionadas a estas otras definiciones
cotidianas de inversión y consumo pero
son un poco más precisas y las
definiciones están hechas de tal manera
que bueno hagan todo más sencillo a la
hora de contabilizar para una nación un
economista define la inversión económica
como el gasto en bienes de capital
bienes de capital donde bienes de
capital son cosas como por ejemplo si tú
tienes una fábrica tú compras los bienes
para que tu fábrica funcione
correctamente compras la maquinaria la
línea de montaje carretillas para bueno
tú sabes etcétera etcétera en bienes de
capital tenemos lo que es el inventario
y bueno no son tan diferentes estas dos
cosas porque bueno ambas son usadas para
producir cosas en el futuro éstas
comprando ese inventario el material le
pondrás valor y será usado para producir
algo en el futuro capital de bienes
incluye cosas como lo que es la
estructura así que bueno lo voy a poner
aquí estructura y a eso me refiero con
edificios y todo lo que todo esto en el
sentido económico
la mayor parte es elaborada por lo que
son las compañías compañías y también
incluye una cosa que hacen los dueños lo
cual es la construcción de casas nuevas
lo voy a poner también aquí casas nuevas
lo cual pertenece a los ocupantes de la
casa ocupantes de la casa
de hecho el comprar una casa nueva no se
muestra ni en consumo o inversión porque
nada nuevo fue producido algo
simplemente cambió de dueño entonces
cuando hablamos de de cualquiera de
estas cosas especialmente en el sentido
estrictamente económico porque hablamos
sobre la producción de nuevo capital de
bienes nuevo inventarios nuevas
estructuras nuevas casas si yo
simplemente compro una fábrica de
alguien más no se suma al pib
no se considera ni inversión ni consumo
porque simplemente estoy transfiriendo
un activo de una persona a otra que
solamente se agregaría el pip si fuera
nuevo y en el lado de consumo desde el
punto de vista de economía consumo se le
considera a cualquier gasto cualquier
gasto en bienes finales fines finales
por ocupantes de la casa excepto excepto
por casas nuevas casas nuevas porque hay
que recordar que si solamente estamos
transfiriendo bienes
entonces casas nuevas no cuenta así que
bueno le pongo aquí en nuevos en nuevos
bienes finales ahora lo que es un poco
intuitivo aquí es bueno que en la manera
en la que aplicamos para el pib la
matrícula que tú pagas por tu educación
son gastos nuevos en bienes o servicios
finales así que bueno deja pongo aquí
servicios y servicios es lo que tú estás
obteniendo en educación
eso sería consumo entonces educación
estaría aquí en el sentido de economía
mientras que en el sentido cotidiano la
educación está acá en
otro ejemplo quizás tú compraste un
carro o un carro nuevo porque lo
necesitas para ir al trabajo no quieres
un carro simplemente por lujo eso sería
una inversión en el sentido cotidiano
comprando ese carro tendrías algo que te
llevara al trabajo día a día eso
beneficiará a tu futuro entonces va a
caer en lo que es inversión pero en
contabilidad
el carro estaría aquí compraste un carro
nuevo pero se considera un consumo y
todo esto se justifica al menos como yo
lo entiendo es porque así se contabiliza
más rápido ves todos los gastos de las
compañías y los contabiliza de una
manera más sencilla esencialmente lo
llamas inversión porque al final de
cuentas todos los gastos que están
haciendo las compañías están haciendo
para producir nuevos bienes y servicios
entonces llamamos a cualquier gasto que
hagan las compañías inversión también
cuando se compra una casa nueva se le
llama a esa inversión simplemente así es
más sencillo para las oficinas que
contabilizan para el gobierno y bueno
siguen el rastro de todo lo que se
compra todo lo otro que hagan los
ocupantes de la casa se le considera
consumo
todos los vídeos veremos que hay otras
categorías en cuanto a lo que se
contabiliza en el pib